I'm gonna blow your mind ready
so Scotland you know Scotland you've
heard of that country Scotland right
you've heard of that place familiar land
of kilts and sheeps but also redheads
but okay and redheads but it's also home
to one of the coolest SAS businesses
that I've ever heard of so it's called
petroleum exports uh they it's known as
uh pet tax
[Music]
let's jump in we got a bunch of stuff
today we're gonna do what's called a
business breakdown duel
Sean and I you know
is that a western duel I guess is uh we
both did a business breakdown and we
didn't know that the other one was gonna
do it and so now we're gonna compare I'm
gonna go first which gives you the
advantage because the person who goes
last always usually wins in rap battles
because that's it's always like when you
you know like when I do you know when
they do the Applause or like person a
person B if person B always wins
I get to hear you say your thing and
then I can make fun of what you said
yeah so anyway you're gonna you get the
advantage but that's okay so I'll go
first okay
but before I go first I've got to give a
shout out to Andrew Lynch from net
income um it's a sub stack it's where I
I found uh this particular business and
I'm just and I'm stealing uh a lot of
his numbers but
I'm gonna blow your mind ready
so Scotland you know Scotland you've
heard of that country Scotland right
you've heard of that place familiar land
of kilts and sheeps but also I think
they're sheeps there I don't actually
know that's how little I know about
Scotland but also redheads but okay and
redheads but it's also home to one of
the coolest SAS businesses that I've
ever heard of so it's called petroleum
exports uh they it's known as uh pet tax
pad tax it's a challenging name I know
and it's a highly technical specialist
software crucial for oil and gas
operations you can go to
p-e-t-e-x.com to check it out so pull
that up but pet pet tax it's a highly
technical specialist software that's the
backbone of some of the most important
operations in the oil and gas industry
and it sounds boring and that's because
it is however
they last year they made 78 million
pounds in Revenue which is about 100
million dollars USD and on that 100
million dollars in Revenue about 67
million of it was profit and of that of
that profit they basically took out all
the money so they paid a dividend of 41
million pounds which is about 60 million
dollars and that was paid to the owner
and it wasn't even retained to the
company which means for every dollar
they took about 52 dollars went directly
to the or 52 cents went directly to the
owner's pocket now
here's the cool part none of this is
rumors this isn't hearsay I'm not like
telling you I heard a story because in
the UK If you're a privately held
company that hits a certain threshold in
Revenue you have to submit your reports
and you could just log in it's called
company's house you can just go there
and you can log in you can see all this
information and so I went and looked at
many many many years of their data and
I'm going to tell you a story about how
this company came to be so it was
started by this guy name we're gonna
call him Aid his name's Abe his name
he's he's a Muslim guy very very very
challenging uh first and last name can
you see his name can you tell me how to
pronounce that do you know how to
pronounce that
is the first name and the last name it's
very challenging there's a d and there's
a j together that's a very challenging
okay so you are calling him ape or he
goes by Abe I'm calling him Abe his last
name is if you look at it if it meant
many Muslim AES but uh we're gonna call
him his last name has a d and a j next
to each other I don't even know how to
pronounce that sound so I'm sorry
it's a very challenging name to
pronounce so he started the company in
1990 it was based in Al Aberdeen
Scotland which is basically like a hub
for oil industry it's kind of like
similar to what Houston in America is
and the company originally served as a
petroleum consultant for in uh
Consultants to the control petroleum
industry as well as retailers and they
would create these mathematical models
to help uh people in the in the oil and
gas industry manage their projects and
so today they've kind of pivoted from
Consulting to providing software they
only have 420 customers and their core
product is composed of complex products
which are complex features that with
descriptions like a multi-phase network
modeling and optimization and thorough
Dynamics fluid characterization package
so pretty complicated stuff so as I said
they started as a Consulting business
and they did have done 78 million pounds
in Revenue last year which is about 100
million USD 58 million USD in profit and
50 million in dividends meaning the
company doesn't require much capital x
so they made all this profit in most all
of it 58 million profit 50 million came
out of the business and went directly to
the owner's pockets and he's been doing
this for years and years and years their
business biggest expense is employees so
because they're based in the UK they pay
UK software engineer salaries which are
lower than the US making their average
all-in cost per each employee of which
they have 86 of them only a hundred and
one thousand pounds per year so the
which means that they are doing 911
pounds 900 911 000 pounds in Revenue per
employee so 9x 9x basically Roi per
person that they hired so yeah this
company absolutely kills it and I want
to tell you when I was analyzing this
company and um if you look up Andrew
Lynch his sub stack he does a really
good job of explaining the technical
details of the company I want to explain
some of the entrepreneurial takeaways
that I had so if you go to the top uh
link Sean in our doc
um or at the beginning of the story
you'll see the sub stack where you can
it's his Andrew Lynch has a thing called
net income and that's where I discovered
this so I want to tell you some of my
takeaways takeaway one Focus plus time
that's what this guy did so everyone
talks about Focus but what does Focus
means you basically in my opinion need
to focus enough to turn your idea into a
machine and then after that I think you
can deviate some attention away from
that if you want but the company needs
focus and that Focus took takes time so
I went back and I looked at a lot of
their uh revenue and so did Andrew so if
you scroll down Sean you'll see a graph
of the revenue and what you'll notice is
that it took them 15 years to get to 10
million dollars in Revenue 10 million
pounds I'm going to call it dollars so
10 million dollars in revenue and I know
a lot of people I think maybe you have
done this with one of your businesses
got to close to 10 million Revenue in
like 1.5 or one or two years actually
and so 15 years particularly in like the
tech Internet space
it feels horribly long but I think
that's okay that's the right feeling and
so
what I try to do something I've been
thinking about for a while is I ask
myself in 10 or 20 years will I be happy
if I started this today and that's a
really good quote
but that answer is incredibly murky more
often than not sometimes it's like a I
think yes it's a very murky thing and
there's this famous story about Jeff
Bezos when he started Amazon he has this
thing called the regret minimalization
framework where he says this story about
he's like well even though he had this
good job I decided to start Amazon
because in 80 years when I meet or when
I'm 80 years old will I be proud that I
started it today the answer was yes but
in that same story he also said that he
thought at most Amazon could make is a
hundred million dollars a year so he
he's not like he had the full picture so
it was like yeah I think this can work
and so I went and talked to darmesh
who's the founder of dharmesha the
founder of HubSpot I also talked to Kip
who was the CMO and Kip joined HubSpot
in year five I asked Kip how big do you
think HubSpot could be when he joined
you know how big did he think so HubSpot
today is worth 25 billion dollars when I
asked him he said I thought he could hit
a billion dollars in valuation there's a
little bit of a stretch but I thought we
could do a billion dollars uh in
valuation meaning like
what's that 80 million in Revenue I
don't know how that's something like
that and then I asked darmesh I go how
big do you think he could get he goes
really I didn't have any idea but I knew
that all I wanted was a thousand
customers who would each pay 250 which
by the way this is only three million
dollars a year in revenue and I thought
that would be a pretty cool Milestone
and so the reason isn't all we or the
outcome isn't always clear of is this
worth it now the reason this is
important is because the biggest pain in
business is not just failing but it's
failing slowly and spending like a
decade working on something and wasting
your the most non-renewable resource
there is time wasting that time and I
mean it's significantly worse I think
than losing millions of dollars a year
in one or two years and then quitting
and so that's where the it's kind of an
art it's a skill it's an intuition it's
Talent that's where all this stuff comes
into place so tactically what does this
mean
Ben Franklin said a small leak will
stake a great ship Warren Buffett said
so you find yourself in a chronically
leaky boat energy devoted to changing
vessels is likely to be more productive
than energy devoted to patching leaks so
the point being only work on [__] as
long as your boat ain't leaking as long
as you don't got any holes in that boat
but here's the thing every early Safe
Company yeah everything's leaky at first
so I went back to darmesh and back to
kit and I go guys tell me about this
HubSpot right now your guys's net
revenue retention I don't know what it
is exactly but I think it's like a
hundred and five percent meaning for
every dollar that someone spends at
HubSpot now the next year they're gonna
spend a dollar and five cents and he
said uh and Chip and uh Kip they said a
few things so I'm gonna mix it up a
little bit but uh or I'm gonna kind of
interchange with what they said but I
believe it was Kip who said our churn at
first was terrible it was beyond bad at
one point we were losing 30 percent of
customers on an annual base on an annual
basis I then asked uh darmesh I go was
your guys's churn really that bad he
goes yeah it was definitely really bad
it took about five years in order to
like get it to where it was a good place
and I said well what did you do to fix
that and he said our goal was not to
make customers happy was to make happy
customers meaning everything from our
branding pitch Marketing sales service
everything should be thought out in a
process where the outcome was a happy
customer and that meant it was
everyone's job marketing needs to be
reaching better fit customers who are
less likely to churn sales needed not
sales shouldn't oversell and make sure
they only qualify that these customers
will likely succeed which helps reduce
the churn products needs to make sure
they don't just build new features but
build a feature that reduces insurance
and they have to make these features
make sure these features get adopted and
churn is churn reduction is a team sport
you also have to remember there's a
power law which is 90 of stickiness will
be driven by 10 of the product and
Company features and not to add 100
features and instead just find ones that
work and double down on those so the
point being
All Ships are leaky at first but
hopefully you can figure out a way to do
it and last but not least my takeaway
ten dollars a month it's rarely gonna
feed a bunch of hungry mouths so our
listeners including you and I sometimes
I do this as well I had a 25 a month
product
a lot of times what we do is we look for
arbitrages or we look for like small
little hacks that's neat that's all cool
and all every once in a while it gives
you that dopamine hit but this company
the reason I like it is you know how
much they charge per year 300 000 a year
for a license to their company they only
have 450 clients
and Andrew in his sub stack article he
said something great he goes imagine
you're running an oil rig that extracts
hundreds of thousands of barrels of oil
per day Brent crude is currently uh
crude is currently trading at 75 per
barrel so every 100 Barrel is 75 7 500
in Revenue your it guy comes up to you
and says boss
attacks just raise their prices by 10 I
think we could save three thousand
dollars annually if we switch software
providers to another thorough Dynamic
fluid characterization package instead
you tell them to piss off don't touch a
thing just make sure nothing breaks it
means like three thousand dollars
there's nothing in the grand scheme of a
huge Capital intense business so they
put their price up 10 and everyone moves
moves on and goes on before because look
it helps them solve their business so or
it helps them solve problems in their
business it makes your business better
so this is my breakdown of this company
I love it I love this company
I love these Scottish guys Jonathan's
giving me a clap what do you think about
this one
yeah Jonathan you like that one oh yeah
that was you you kind of touched it all
you got the opening story hit with the
impact and then the three big takeaways
at the end and that like q a with Kiff
and darmesh was a nice touch yeah that
was a good touch I like how you brought
that in the um
there was a a bit of a spelling and
pronunciation challenge at the beginning
but you overcame that and I'm proud of
you for doing that you know what I say I
so I went to speech class when I was a
kid by the way and I always used to tell
people I just got a big tongue my
tongue's real thick I got a thick tongue
it's something I'm big tongued yeah I
got I got fat Thug a pet see I give it a
fat tongue it's like a it's like a it's
like a snail in there it's like a slug I
got a slug of a tongue I got molasses in
my mouth I don't know what to say it's
hard for me to say some words sometimes
it's like the further away from St Louis
a person gets or a company gets like the
harder it is to explain them
um that's interesting you know I I guess
two days on mine right now I bet there's
opportunity to create like
another pedex basically which is uh with
machine learning and AI
you could go into these kind of like
Old School Big dollar type companies and
be like hey look we have the ability to
process your data or to give you
insights that's going to save you money
like yeah 10 efficiency gain 20
efficiency gains and I bet that these
opportunities you know have existed but
the the more powerful mlna I get the
more those opportunities open up and the
bottleneck is people who even understand
what problems exist inside of uh you
know some Shale gas company or inside of
Exxon Mobil and then being able to go
sell into them there was a guy who I met
very early on when I was doing my
startup I didn't really know any other
entrepreneurs but there's one guy who
also went to Duke
and I wonder what happened to him I
haven't kept in touch but I think his
name was Evan Anderson and he was
building a company that was
um
selling to I was called osberg yeah this
is exactly right let's see what happened
with this company
um so it was selling to
um companies that were in Oklahoma so I
was like well you moved to Oklahoma and
he was like yeah this is what our
customers are and I was like who's your
customers and it was like all the oil
and gas companies that uh that are in
America and what he was doing at that
time was basically quote-unquote Big
Data uh big data for oil and gas and I
was like that's a great idea I'm looking
at it now he's still there CEO 14 years
later so I've got this company's been
been pretty successful and I was like I
would check in with him and be like you
know what's the challenge and at this
time I'm working on a sushi restaurant
chain and he's like you know I'll spend
six months just courting the right guy
the right suit at this uh at this
company I gotta take him to uh you know
a football game I gotta invite his
family over we got to get to know him we
got to get him comfortable with this uh
you know the software but once I get
once I close that deal
these deals are going to be worth
millions and millions of dollars over
time they're never going to rip us out
once we get in and so um I I'm curious
how this company is doing today but I
know that you know 15 years ago I was
like this is a great idea and I just I I
intuitively knew it because I was like
the same effort it's taking me to do
this silly sushi restaurant thing he's
spending the same amount of time he's
just working for a much bigger prize
with much more defensibility and a much
clearer value where he's going into an
industry that's like never had uh you
know doesn't have this this sort of
software capability he's like I will sit
here until I understand your problems
and then I will build solutions for this
and I just love that approach I think
that's a like if people are willing to
kind of like eat [__] and go outside of
their like kind of comfort zone of
problem areas they understand there's
pretty big opportunities
yeah and it's cool did you see this
graph from Andrew Lynch of this
company's Revenue yeah it's just like a
perfect hockey stick but over a long
period of time over a really long period
of time I mean that's something you want
to talk about like this 15 years to get
to 10 million
you know respect for continuing and
making it all work
that's not for me what's the boys quote
uh why is everyone make fun of getting
rich quick it's the best way to get rich
and I'm going to tell you about a
company in a second here that said in
their first week they did a million
dollars of sales and never went less
than that from there and you think that
that's not true correct I think it's I
think it's a lie but I love a good lie I
love a good life tell me about this give
me a good underestimate how much of uh
startup stories are just lies okay so
here's my here's my big business
breakdown I see your duel and I uh I
raise you
um In My Head by the way we were doing
an old-fashioned Western duel but now I
decided it's American Gladiators and
your laser non-blazer and we're going at
it on the chest but so
this morning I was thinking about
who's lying out there who's lying men's
problems
that way okay so most people have heard
apparently you got a little you got a
little situation is that the issue
no no no that's not how we got actually
here's the here's the actual train of
thought I was thinking about
um these T-Shirt Company a little segue
here to tell you how my brain works so
the thing about these t-shirt companies
I don't know if you've seen this but
basically in the last kind of like four
years
there's been a bunch of companies start
started that succeeded that did the most
obvious thing and I've seen this happen
again and again that there's these
windows of time
where Big Ideas are just hidden in plain
sight
and so basically in the last four years
a bunch of companies have started to do
such a simple thing they just sell basic
plain men's t-shirts and these were the
Big d2c Ideas so like anybody who wanted
to do e-commerce or Drop Shipping or d2c
build a brand
the opportunity was sitting right in
front of everybody it was just men's
t-shirts so you have Cuts fresh clean
tees true classic tees built Basics all
of these companies that in the last sort
of four year window have built 100
million dollar plus companies so some of
them do about 50 million a year in sales
some of them do 100 or 150 million
dollars a year in sales so this kind of
range but to go in like a three year
period to get to 150 million in sales
that's what true classic tees did
is just bananas to be honest and so
um I'll tell you the uh the numbers for
True classic so year one uh let's see
where the video so I think go okay
you're one 15 million you're two 90
million you're three 150 million in top
line revenue and um and they did it all
through Facebook ads selling plain you
know white black blue men's t-shirts and
that's the same thing I think fresh
clean teas is somewhere like 50 million
north of 50 million in Revenue uh I
think Cuts is over 100 million
um
it's crazy that these companies all
scaled so fast doing this such an
obvious thing where is the there was no
massive Innovation and so I was thinking
about this I was like man there's these
windows of time and then I thought about
what what are other windows that I've
seen like this and I stayed in the
e-commerce world and I thought about oh
back in 2017 both Roman and hymns
launched doing basically the same thing
and they launched within like a couple
months of each other basically people
had the same idea at the same time and
both of them became Billion Dollar Plus
companies doing the same thing what they
did was you know I guess the summary is
they took advantage of a uh what do we
call it an inflection uh Sam blows this
regulation inflection in this case well
this was a regulation inflection this is
a regulatory inflection and so what
happened was
um there was proven market demand for
drugs like Viagra uh or Propecia or
Rogaine and so hair loss or erectile
dysfunction there was a proven like
business there and they started like in
the early 90s and so by 2017 the patents
expired for those and when the patents
expired have you ever taken a Viagra or
anything like that
haven't have you no but if someone if
someone told me it's awesome I would but
I've never thought it's awesome go
so so the patents expired and basically
now there was like generic versions of
these and so what and at the same time
there's another regulatory inflection
which was that telemedicine was becoming
more and more things were getting opened
up for telemedicine meaning you could
prescribe drugs without going to the
doctor so drugs without a doctor was the
key kind of like just you know frame uh
framework for for this type of business
and so they both launch and the hymns
guy says this guy Andrew uh dude him he
goes we launched and in our first week
we did a million dollars of sales and
we've never done less than a million
since then I was like wow that is
incredible and it is true that him
scaled really quickly so their revenue a
week so he said they never did he said
they never did less than a million a
week after watching yes oh is that and I
was like that's insane I was thinking
about that because I was like I've
launched many things the first week is
you're talking about patching holes on a
boat that's how the first week is it's
like you don't even have inventory you
don't have you don't have a million
dollars of inventory you don't have like
to do a million dollars how much are you
spending an ad did you just blast like
half a million dollars of ads in your
first week Facebook ads doesn't even let
you ramp up that quickly so I was a
little bit suspicious of this and uh the
revenue did ramp quickly so they
launched the very end of 2017 2018 the
full year they did 27 million dollars in
Revenue with 27 million dollars in ad
spend so they spent 100 of Revenue on
ads so they burned a bunch of money uh
2019 they did they went from 27 million
to 83 million and they spent 50 million
on ads 2020 they were forecasting about
140 million and then I have the actual
so check out this Revenue girl it's
pretty insane 2021 they did 270. 2022
they did 540. 2023 they're projecting to
finish at 800 million in Revenue so this
is a pretty crazy run in uh what six
years to ramp up to 800 million and and
revenue so they can get a billion in
Revenue in seven years exactly they're
burning money this whole time even now
even at 500 million last year they only
have two percent even a margin and
that's the adjusted ebitda the rule they
actually burn 10 million but the the
adjusted is that they you know they they
made a a small two percent uh margin and
so super Capital intensive they raised
like 200 something million dollars
before going public and they didn't
going public another
to 300 million dollars went into the
business I think and so it's taken them
a lot of capital to get here so I would
say three things
Amazing Story just in general like props
to them for pulling this off like they
built this out of an incubator I ran an
incubator for six years and couldn't get
one thing to even 10 million in revenue
and they this was like a big hit that
came out of a a incubator which is very
very rare
Roman which now rebranded wrote also
came out of an incubator at the same
time so they're the two biggest
incubator hits were sort of the these
two companies that did the same thing
essentially one did it for hair so I
think uh hymns did it for hair hair loss
and Road did it for Ed and then they
both just added the other product as
they went
um so impressive in that way the revenue
growth impressive the ad spend and the
money burned incredible I now question
is this even a good business so like
they basically showed that their
their CAC so their cost to acquire
customers uh is really high like their
cost to acquire customers is basically
what do I have it here it's like 100
plus dollars to acquire a customer let
me grab it
um I think it's like 150 on average to
to acquire a customer the lowest it's
been is like a hundred dollars to
acquire a customer and
um they basically think they think they
3x their money in three years which is
actually not very good for Ecom like my
Ecom business which is nowhere near the
scale of this
is way more efficient than this like
they're trying to pay back essentially
you know a little over a year uh you
know we're trying to pay back in in two
months and so like you know it's amazing
what just pure aggression uh they
approach this business with they were
just like yeah we're gonna scale this
thing and we're gonna pour a bunch of
money in we're gonna burn a bunch of
money but we're gonna ramp up and like
we're gonna try to thread the needle to
get this business to work when it's at
the billions in in scale and um they
kind of pulled it off because they went
public with vs back and they got liquid
before the business really worked this
week I had to chop down a tree at my
farm and I didn't have an ax so I just
used a sledgehammer instead and so my
wife was like oh do you you chopped down
that tree I was like I I gotta smashed
it down and uh I just sludged him
hammered it down and that's kind of what
these guys did they just kind of
sledgehammered their way into into the
market
have you seen this guy that's on Tick
Tock that just chops the tree and all
like it gets like a million views and
it's all there's like hundreds of
thousands of women commenting like
like just like gasp like I need him yeah
shirtless no is he shirtless and hot is
he shirtless and he just chops the tree
perfectly like it's like it takes them
like
10 Strokes to crack down this giant tree
is that like a innuendo for sex or
something
literally like I'm watching this thing
and I'm like I don't even know why I'm
watching this this is like just
from a purely objective level this is
very attractive
I'm just gonna say this this is hat
he just wears like suspenders
he looks like a lumberjack but he's like
gq'd out so he's he's like a groomed
lumberjack that's super like with a
CrossFit body that chops down trees
instead of going to the gym since he's
incredible so um you're kind of like
that you're like that but like you know
[Laughter]
so that's basically what these guys did
they kind of brute force their way but
why don't you think this is a good
business
well I think that the I mean just the
amount of capital it took to get to this
business value so it's worth 1.8 billion
on paper
um and they've taken 500 million to get
here so like if you just zoom out it's
like
we three and a half extra money like
that's not the most impressive thing but
like when you frame it the other way
which is like we're gonna hit a billion
dollars in sales and we've done this in
seven years and like you know we've
built the largest telemedicine Health
company for men and women and you could
frame it one way or you could just kind
of look at another it's like now here's
a business where if I have to pay 150 to
acquire a customer and give takes two
years to pay it back if if that we'll
see how it all projects out it's super
sensitive to like you know they pour so
much money into marketing and what if
you know Facebook costs change like you
know How's that gonna affect them like
there's all these factors I'm not saying
it's a bad business but
like compared to that pedex company that
does 100 million in sales and dividends
out 50 million to the owner
I know which business I would want to
own right uh the business that didn't
need us back
to to succeed as the business I would
want to own the one that's dividending
out like a mega yacht every year to this
guy like that's sick and it has like you
know one one millionth of the notoriety
of a brand like it some others you say
about the uh yeah tell me the the other
interesting so so other cool things so
so there's some notable things for the
research I want to put these on the
screen so I put the put the images on
screen on YouTube if you're listening to
the podcast just pause go to YouTube
because you got to see these so if you
go back through their history uh first
take a look at this thing I have on page
uh what is this page like three or
something of this the p l do you see
this p l
um this was in their S1 to go public
it's literally it just says Revenue
27. gross profit eight adjusted Ebina
minus 68. that's the p l they shared in
their investor presentation I was like
what kind of
a kindergarten level of detail is this
what kind of crayon p l are you doing
like this is [__] ridiculous and I
was like this is why spax this is why
spax went to [__] because it's like half
the p l is just projections what you
can't do if you go public the
traditional way but in spax you can do
these like forward-looking projections
and that's how all these guys got away
with it it's like we got a shitty
business now but like five years from
now we're crushing and that's like you
know they were able to tell that story
whereas you can't make forward-looking
statements in the traditional way of
going public
and then I was like this is some
absolute basic beginner looking thing I
I was just stunned that this this is
like on the SEC website that's a that's
an embarrassment uh all right second
thing you can go to their website
and you can find in the web archive
their landing page from the beginning so
check this out this was their first
landing page this is like the month that
they launched it just said guy against
staggering odds two things happen one
the universe two you you let's walk at
our full height honor our forebearers
have a smile and for God's sakes floss
shop now and it just go it just Scrolls
down and it just says sex this is this
is simple you need erections when you
want them and not when it's convenient
for your penis and there's an eggplant
Emoji it says shop sex and there was
another one for hair like that was like
the same it was like she needs to run
her fingers through your hair a lot and
then it just says our best sellers and
there's just a very basic bottle that
says finasteride and that's like the the
generic name for Propecia or like you
know for like the hair uh male pattern
baldness like drug or whatever and they
were just selling it for 28 and then
there was they only had two skews
finasteride and vitamins not even like
vitamin C this is yes but here's some
vitamins and so incredible to go see I
love love love looking at successful
businesses early landing pages just to
see like how did they get their business
out the door one thing that's
interesting is from the beginning they
actually had a pretty strong like
branding and brand identity so if you go
do this with like Snapchat or Uber the
first websites are just absolutely fugly
like um I have this blog post on the
internet that's called like you just
search Sean Prairie uh early startup
landing pages medium
um 10th okay it's called 10 throwback
startup home pages
um when did you write that article I
wrote this in 2015. so this was one
month what month June oh you beat me on
October 12 2015 I wrote an article that
said proof that your favorite startup
started out awful and it's a list of 10
landing pages yeah
to each other then so uh you can go look
at airbnbs it's like literally plain
black and white and it's just says
forget hotels stay with a local Uber it
looks like a you know janky thing
everyone's private driver but it looks
like a old school car service Snapchat
it's got one of these like yellow
bubbles that's like the like buy now you
know like you know half buy two get one
and it just says free download inside
and it says introducing Snapchat
real-time picture chatting for iPhone
and it's two girls and they're like
bikinis and it just says seven seconds
on the screen and like you know a
self-destructing photo so you can see
what early startup landing pages look
like what's interesting that was unique
in the hymns case is that they actually
had their branding from day one which I
think was a smart move by them and they
specifically branded it the opposite
colors as every other male Wellness
product so every other Wellness product
is essentially blue and they were like
no we'll go all neutral color scheme
lowercase like lowercase font for the
for the brand name and we're gonna make
it subtle because there's a stigma and a
taboo around this it's not something you
want to brag about we don't want bold we
want like we want to be able to give you
this package in a discrete way and you
know and I know and that's all who needs
to know and I thought that was like a
smart thing for them to get right from
day one
all their models are like it's usually
like a cool looking black dude or like a
racially ambiguous guy it's like some
it's like oh I I can see myself in you
I'm a young cool guy with like I wear
like cool jeans as well were your
parents all of the Power Rangers why are
you also like that's what happened here
it's usually like a like a pretty
racially ambiguous good-looking guy with
nice teeth yeah yeah the tea throw is on
point versus like a Viagra is always
like Brett Favre looking guy and then
this was one of their early
um early ads so it's just uh it just
says get hard or get your money back and
it's just a guy holding a tiny pill
um and it's and then what ethnicity is
that guy
oh dude his hand is like a gradient in
Photoshop it's like all all colors are
easy here uh so it says eggplant Emoji
rise to the occasion for Less so one
thing that they did really well was they
figured out how do you advertise on
Facebook with a taboo product so they
would do stuff like they would show a
picture of a cactus that was limp and
then another and it would be like with
hymns you don't have this problem so
like how do you and so they were very
clever with their marketing they also
did stuff where they would create ad
inventory so they would go to
um like stadiums and they'd be like all
right a bunch of guys who are in our
demographic are at the stadium we could
either spend like four hundred thousand
dollars to get on the Jumbotron and uh
along with like you know BMW and a bunch
of other big brands or they went to the
stadium facility manager and they were
like hey how much for the urinal space
you're like what it's like yeah we want
to put a little ad on the urinal and
we'll give you guys like you know X
price to be in every urinal and they're
like yeah dude we got like 30 seconds of
guys focused time while they're touching
their thing like you know looking at our
ad this is actually kind of perfect and
so they would create new ad inventory
that didn't even exist before just
trying to figure out how do we spend 100
million dollars in a way that's going to
be as efficient as possible so they're
you know really just like very they're
like a very Advanced marketing agency
essentially
[Music]
worst have you heard of HubSpot see most
trms are a cobble together mess but
HubSpot is easy to adopt and actually
looks gorgeous I think I love our new
CRM our software is the best HubSpot
grow better
and another thing that they did I did a
big breakdown on this one time was so if
you Google Viagra alternative or cheap
Viagra or buy Viagra online they show up
number one and what they did was they
actually sponsored a ton of twitch
people and somehow that like got their
links out there and they like they got
tons and tons of backlinks really early
on so hymns.com ranked quite high so
they were able to get like it was I
think if you I think it's Viagra
alternative might be like their word I
forget which it's one of those pages and
that's where they got most of the
revenue early on oh wow that's
interesting you know there's another
cool thing I'll put this graphic on the
stream
um it's this graphic from have you ever
read Sakura by the way I don't know if
that's how you say it yeah yeah like the
research thing I like it yeah they're
pretty cool uh I don't think people know
about them but it's uh like really good
research
s-a-c-r-a yeah so they had done a thing
and they had this great graphic which is
basically they were like telemedicine
was like this like Trend like this like
there's a lot of opportunity in
telemedicine right now and they just
showed this picture of like a guy and a
girl and it's a diagram and basically
it's like you could look from like head
to toe
literally from head to toe and you just
go down the body you're like okay hair
there's hymns there's keeps there's
Roman okay then you go down to like eyes
and it's like there's a prescription
contact Hubble um you know it was it was
a DVC startup doing prescription
contacts through a phone app instead of
going to the doctor
then you go to their bicep it's like trt
uh there's a bunch of trt companies like
hone health and others and then you're
like and then you go to uh you know
their abs like weight loss you go to the
crotch it's like here's the erectile
dysfunction you go down to the toes like
here's toe fungus he's got a little putt
next to him it's like hey here's pop
it's it's insurance for your pet so you
have like instead of going to the vet
for everything you can use pop and um
and so it's like
uh and then they do the same thing for
women and you could just literally see
like if you've seen those diagrams that
were like there was a big opportunity to
unbundle Craigslist and they took
Craigslist homepage and they showed out
every little section of Craigslist
became its own billion dollar startup
they did the same thing to your body
every part of your body became a billion
dollar startup essentially from one d2c
wellness company and uh or or multiple
in some in some areas so from Skin Care
all of their logos look exactly the same
lowercase font pastel colors
hymns I think it's oh by the way one one
other little observation
a lot of these DDC successes came from a
certain type of founder not all of them
but many from NBA found like Founders
who went to like Business Schools which
is funny because like in the startup
World Business Schools
kind of like our easy punching bag
because you're like punching up at the
institution it's easy to make fun of
them like bro you don't learn business
from school you learn business by doing
business and that's how I feel to be
honest with you so I'm like that's true
but there is something interesting that
a lot of DDC companies Blue Apron
Birchbox Stitch fix Warby Parker
um Rent the Runway
hellofresh
um and then this you know this guy who
did uh uh hymns he went to Wharton as
well so it's like a lot of these big I
think there was something about the type
of person who would do well in a
business school and the types of things
you learn in business school where you
like do this Market landscape you like
figure out the opportunities you're like
okay good I just need to be like good in
marketing and then good at operations in
order to like like put cash in here and
get thing out it's not like very
software based it's not in it you don't
have to be the the innovator who's like
you know the one inventor of something
um
I think it lended itself to that type of
entrepreneur which I found pretty
interesting too
well here's what our listeners need to
do they need to either probably in the
YouTube comments they need to let us
know I actually want to do who on The
Duel I actually want them to I want to
know if they think Kansas is a good
business but also who won the duel so
you'll have to vote by saying our names
um we'll include a Spotify poll as well
so you can just vote in the app
and we'll do a Spotify poll as well if
some guy in the YouTube channel said um
um who's this blonde host and why is he
so annoying so just for the record the
blonde annoying guy
that's what someone said in the comment
the the blonde annoying guy that was Sam
I went first and Sean is the brown less
annoying guy he went second for him so
let us know who's the winner here of the
of this duel
um I'm very eager to hear uh what people
gonna say I know which one I would
rather own but I think they're both
quite interesting
for sure for sure
you saw this post by Mark Zuckerberg
that he did the Murph
I tweeted out the picture of it and it
got like five million views it kind of
took off and I don't know so do you know
what the Murph is
I had never heard of the Murph until I
saw this and then I was like I must do
the Murph it's named after lieutenant
Murphy I believe context clues leads me
to believe that he died uh in the
military and uh his favorite workout I
believe it's one mile run
300 squats a hundred push-ups and 100
pull-ups and then I'm one mile run all
while wearing a 20 pound weighted vest
is that the workout
that's exactly right run a mile 100
pull-ups 200 push-ups 300 squats run
another mile while wait while wearing a
20 pound vest
and uh Zuck basically takes a like bro
gym shot I gotta use the Blackberry for
this he's got the phone down here
not smiling got the mouth open just
and just snaps it with himself drenched
in sweat and he's like just did the
Murph
um
he's like me and my daughters dude he's
got a picture of his daughters doing
like push-ups and he goes I this year I
got it done in 39 minutes and 58 seconds
and I was like I read that and I was
like hmm that sounds like really fast if
he had just said I did 100 pull-ups
today I would have been like man what a
day fantastic forget all the rest I was
already impressed by 100 Pull-Ups to say
he got that done
weighted Pull-Ups
so say you got that done in 39 minutes I
was like that sounds ridiculously fast
and sure enough all the comments were
like that's an insane time for the Murph
have you ever done this workout I
haven't but the world record holder of
the Murph is this guy named Hunter
McIntyre who's dm'd me on Twitter and
Instagram and I've talked to because I
like him a lot or I followed him and I
feel like I like him is that what fit
guys do they just DM each other yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's like a club you know
like once you can see the sixth app you
start smelling each other yeah I'm one
of us
good to see you and he DN me he listens
to the pot he's the world record holder
and I think his world record is like 34
minutes and zuck's time was 39 minutes
which means he would have gotten like
10th or 15th Place at there's like a
Murph gains or something like that
I mean I had so many thoughts brushed
through my head when I saw this first I
saw 39 minutes and I thought
I've taken shits longer than that like
that's a that's a crazy fast time then I
thought I don't think I could even do a
Murph in an infinite amount of time I
don't think in my life I have done a
total
of two miles running 100 pull-ups 200
push-ups and 300 air squats like with a
20 pound vest I have just never done it
period uh so my time is currently 35
years then I thought
this mother this guy has
he decided yo you know what I'll just
become one of the richest people in the
world one of the most powerful people in
the world and the one of the fittest
guys in the world like he's basically
wholesome top point one percent wealth
top point one percent you know
intelligence top point one percent power
and now he's top Point top one point one
percent Chad also I am all before the
age of 40.
yeah exactly and he's got two kids or
something like that I'm like
I mean David Goggins should go to sleep
listening to Mark Zuckerberg videos for
motivation this guy is incredible I went
I bought more stock and I bought a plain
gray you know cookie cutter t-shirt in
his honor I was like this is I'm gonna
retire this is the rafters of my office
I'm gonna put it I'm gonna hang a gray
shirt just to honor this man he can get
so much [__] and man he's really turned
his like public Persona around like do
you remember he was
he was the biggest dork like not just
like oh when he was young like
recently he was the biggest dork is that
he tried to do something cool like he
would do when he did that like Hydro
foiling thing and he painted his fight
his face white like a geisha and like
it's like man this guy's like
and hit American fight it was just like
it was like oh man like you know what
keep all your money I don't want to be
here and now he's like
you know just got off work did a quick
Jiu Jitsu tournament came back you know
[__] deleted Snapchat off the Earth
I'm like wow this guy's just this guy's
making power moves all day he's
incredible he's he's a very
inspirational dude he's done it Scandal
free so Zuck is only 37 now you know
probably fifth or sixth is he's only 37.
something like that I mean he's still in
his 30s how old is he
39 39. so he so basically he uh been
married to the same woman been with her
since college has two kids seems like
his family life on on paper seems
awesome there was a time when like the
most scandalous thing that he did was he
had a video where he talked about
smoking meats and every year he sets you
remember that because every year he has
goals no no that's not the scandalous
thing that was just like hilarious that
he was a robot trying to be like hello
humans I am doing a barbecue with I have
flesh on a grill with fire and I was
like bro this is the robot the most
scandalous thing he did was when he was
in college and the the his aim messages
got leaked that was like you know a real
wonderful day in my household as I like
was like Hey cancel Netflix I have my
entertainment for the week I'm reading
all of Mark Zuckerberg's aim messages
for the next week that and it wasn't
even that big of a deal what he said was
pretty on par with an 18 year old 19
year old person like well
maybe it was one part was a little bit
like uh is this what we want like this
guy's this is the guy running Facebook
where he was like he's like yeah he's
like he's like yeah just tell me if you
want anyone's like you know name do you
know date of birth you know address
whatever he's like these dumb [__] just
just trust me they just put everything
in the system and so yeah like something
a 19 year old kid who invented this
stuff would say
yeah I would say that was the last time
I was relatable with Mark Zuckerberg
ever since then he's created a gap and
he's outpaced me from there every year
he sets these goals one year it was he
only wants to eat food that he killed or
grew and I think he did it and then
another year he was like I'm gonna learn
Mandarin because I want Facebook to come
to China and I think his wife is Chinese
and he was like I'm Gonna Learn man
and then he goes and he gives a talk I
think he does it gives a talk to a
Chinese Universe he gave me an interview
they go he they fly him out there
they're like thank you so much Mark
Zuckerberg for coming we are so happy to
have you and he's like he's like yo well
Mitchell and he just starts speaking
Chinese and they're like blown away it's
like really great Amanda where he's
basically fluent and so the guy kills it
man he does great and like when he did
the E4 so he got into e-foiling which is
basically surfboarding without a wave
and he is doing it with an American flag
and he has too much sunscreen on his
face that's my guy a guy whose biggest
like flaw is that he's goofy it's not
the I know my guy and then now that I
said you're zagging the other way you're
saying Zuck bad move unrelatable too too
good no vulnerability no no relatability
now he's no longer Girl Next Door hot
now he's just super model hot it sucks
the best man he just he you know our
friend Nikita beer uh has this joke
where he said something like I would
never I forget why he says this but he
says never ever ever bet against Zuck
how he's just a complete killer and he
is wrong sometimes but not in the grand
scheme and this is for the proof well
the funny thing is people will hate this
segment because I think it's popular to
really hate Mark Zuckerberg
um
because they hate Facebook I think
because they're like my data or like the
Russians hacked the election I'm not
even sure I'm not even sure what the
what the exact reason is for hating
Zuckerberg at this point I just gotta
say like this is
I mean he he is inspiring in that he is
excellent and if you appreciate
Excellence that is kind of inspiring
it's kind of like people who hate LeBron
it's like okay I get it you don't have
to like the guy but uh I mean you gotta
respect that puts a perspective on this
guy's name is wrong either by the way
like people played sometimes
yeah exactly yeah it might yeah he
switched teams when he was a free agent
um my real estate agent told me the
story that she was driving my she's like
that's Mark Zuckerberg's house in the in
the mission
kind of like near Dolores Park type of
area and I was like he lives here and I
was like that's not like I thought he'd
live in some private gated community and
she was like well let me think he has
like many houses but this is one this is
one and this is like his main one for a
while
and she's like and he made it private I
said what do you mean I don't see any
fence and she's like no he bought the
houses next door like he just bought all
the houses in the area so that like you
know whatever and so he he knocked on
someone's door himself
so somebody opened the door and it was
Mark Zuckerberg outside and he's like
hey you know I love this house and I
would you sell it to me and they're like
no I mean it's not for sale we love this
house we're so close to the park you
know my commute it's only seven miles
he's like I'll give you 10 million
dollars and you're like okay here's the
keys basically he bought the house for
10 million it was probably a two million
dollar house uh and the house next like
the house is nearby two and a half three
billion dollars and he paid ten and just
got the house right away dude that
person who sold their house to him would
be the best dinner guest imagine that
story we'd like to have you on air if
that's you we would like to have you
come tell that story because uh
obviously I'm reenacting what I was told
by a real estate agent I don't know if
that's that's true or that's [__]
um
so yeah Zuck amazing Let's uh wrap up
with this last thing this Nike thing
did you watch this movie uh air yeah I
did I thought it was awesome it was
pretty sweet right like uh not the best
movie but like a just a solid base hit
on a Thursday night a Friday night you
know you just need something that's I
don't want to sit here and browse
Netflix for the perfect thing
all right I'm just gonna go on I think
it's on Amazon and I'm just gonna go
watch air and like this just watch the
story of
how Nike signed Michael Jordan they made
Phil Knight look like a doofus
yeah why did they do that I didn't
understand that they uh well he does
like appearance-wise look like a doofus
but they also made him act like a doofus
yeah which I don't think he was like
that when I read true dog I didn't get
that idea he he he he he's more I think
uh they made him look like when he wrote
his own Memoir he made himself sound
cool well I've read a lot I've read a
lot about him he he they just kind of
made him look like a like a like a ditzy
person like an idiot yeah he's not an
idiot
um but the guy they feature so a couple
things so so first uh anything stand out
from the movie air but then I have I
want to go deep on this guy Sonny
Vaccaro because I think he's actually
more interesting
who was that the main character I don't
remember his name that's that's the main
character so that's Matt Damon uh Matt
Damon in the movie but um you know in in
Nike in the air movie I thought one one
is something I didn't know was they're
they're talking about just do it which
is the just do it's the slogan that you
know everybody knows it's the Nike kind
of like iconic slogan and they were
talking about like at the time even
people internally were like just do it
like they got that from the Ad Agency
Wyden Kennedy and they're like I don't
know what what does that what does that
mean do you like it it's like I don't
know it's okay I guess they weren't like
yes this is this is gonna be this like
marketing Masterpiece and they go what
does that even mean and they go dude
it's from an inmate on death row who was
about to be assassin about to be
executed and they were like any last
words and he goes just do it
so that became the Nike slogan which is
uh honestly kind of Genius
um
so I want to talk about this guy Sonny
Vaccaro because he's kind of a gangster
that I've seen for many many years in
the basketball scene
and the movie was about him and he this
guy's pretty fascinating so
what uh in the movie he's famous because
he's working at Nike at the time Nike is
the last player it's just a running shoe
company and they're the smaller shoe
company uh Adidas is This Global brand
that's crushing it they own most of the
sneaker Market uh I believe it's
pronounced Adidas yeah Adidas
which has its own interesting story then
Reebok is like number two and Nike's
like a distant three but they were doing
like 27 million a year in sales through
their running shoot so good but not like
nowhere near the kind of top tier uh of
shoe companies and so Sunny meets Phil
Knight and he's like hey I got an idea
for a basketball shoe I want to create
like a basketball Division like you guys
are all running shoes which is great
basketball shoes and he's like okay like
come on in and you get this little
basketball Department like go ahead try
to make it work
and the movie is all about like one
breakthrough thing he did which was
they had a tiny budget and in the 1984
draft they decided to sponsor Michael
Jordan and Michael Jordan was not
interested in Nike he was going to go
with uh I think Adidas or somebody like
that and um
he was known as a hot Prospect he's like
the number three pick and they were like
well we still want and and Sonny was
convinced we need Michael Jordan and so
the movie's about them trying to go get
Michael Jordan on Borden and what ended
up what they what the pitch was was
basically they put her entire Budget on
one guy instead of spreading across
multiple players
he relentlessly pursued Jordan and like
met his mom and like just like drove out
there to North Carolina to meet them and
try to build a relationship and then
they didn't even showed Jordan's face in
the movie which actually was pretty cool
it was basically the whole relationship
was how do I impress his mom because I
know his mom will have my back she's
making the decisions and so they were
like well
um we're gonna pitch him on his own
signature shoe from day one and we're
gonna name it after him
um so it'll be the Air Jordan it'll be a
whole product line named after him and
he ended up negotiating a royalty on
every pair of Jordans sold and that's
how Michael Jordan became a billionaire
not through basketball but through his
shoes so that's the movie part okay cool
this guy Sonny actually did a bunch of
other interesting things that I thought
were pretty cool so as a marketer I just
respect this guy's hustle so here's some
of the things he did to make Nike win
um he created so he was like all right
we gotta create like um like a kid's
strategy it's like how do we get him
while they're young and so he created a
high school All-American Game so he was
like he called it the uh the Dapper band
round ball classic he goes throughout
the country he's like I'm inviting you
to participate you're going to compete
against you know the the 12 best players
um we're gonna have 20 best players in
the country you're invited to come do
this thing in in Pittsburgh or
Philadelphia or some [__] like that and
it was like uh and so he flies them out
there and he puts this thing together
now he's got the players so then he goes
and tells all the college coaches hey if
you're scouting you need to come to this
round ball class you can see all the
best high school players at once and so
then college coaches start coming so now
players are like oh if I want to get
seen by college coaches I gotta get to
the high school All-American Game so he
just like created through Brute Force
like a conference essentially that would
uh bring together the kind of the core
supply and demand and then he could find
at that age the best young players and
so he that's how he found Kobe Bryant
that's how he found LeBron James they
were part of his high school
All-American things in his Camp so the
second thing he did was he created a
summer camp for only the best players
called ABCD any brand this is when he
was with Adidas so this guy worked for
Nike then he worked for Adidas then he
worked for Reebok so he just this guy
was just a hired assassin that went from
company to company and would just try to
get them to win in their Market using
whatever advantages they had and so when
Nike needed something he was like all
right you need to get them while they're
young we're gonna do this camp but also
what we're going to do is we need to get
college players wearing our stuff they
all wear Adidas and uh because it's the
most popular brand so that's just what
they choose by default or they choose
Converse and so he's like you know why
don't we um you can't pay College
athletes
but nobody say anything about coaches
and so he just started he would go to
the coaches and he'd be like hey I'm
gonna give you 10 grand and here's 26
pairs of shoes give them out oh they
happen to be the sizes of like most of
your guys uh they don't have to wear
them you get the 10 grand either way but
we sure do hope you would uh you know
you would go ahead and uh and um you
know encourage them to wear these shoes
and so he went to Jim beehive and he
went to like you know all the top
college coaches and he basically bribed
them and it was like in this gray area
where it was allowed and in one year he
just traveled like he would just fly
City to City he would go to the campus
he would make the coach and offer and at
the time they were buying this equipment
for their program they're like our kids
need equipment so we got to buy this the
stuff so we turn to cost into revenue
for them and gave them free stuff and
sure enough all of them started wearing
Nikes for free so all of a sudden now
Nike's being worn by all the best
college players and it's on TV and in
one year he just did a land grab across
the country before the other companies
could could react he got all of them and
I thought this was just like a genius uh
genus strategy he started
how far you can go with Brute Force
this was a sledgehammer this was a
sledgehammer and you can get pretty far
with the sledgehammer
then then he did another thing he sued
the NCAA so he went to this guy Edo
Bannon and he was like hey we should sue
the NCAA they're using your name your
face you're like this to market the
tournament and all the stuff and you're
getting nothing from it and now college
players can get paid through this nil
rule this name and like this thing and
it's because he won the case with that
uh lawsuit uh against the NCAA that was
like you know it happened the lawsuit
happened the last time about five years
or so then the rule came into effect
like a year ago or something and so um
so I thought that was awesome uh there
were some great quotes about him some
guy goes uh
when Sonny dies he's gonna sneak his way
into heaven and uh and when he gets
there the first thing he's gonna do is
he's gonna look for a six nine kid to
make a deal with like he's like and the
other thing they said is there's only
one man on Earth who could tell you who
the best sixth grade basketball player
in the country is and it's sunny Vaccaro
and I just love that this guy just like
owned his Niche and just absolutely like
went balls to the wall and really built
like I don't know tens of billions of
value at least inside of Nike Plus
Adidas plus Reebok with these athletes
and he would have also gotten so he
signed Jordan he sang he he got he
poached Kobe away from Adidas and that
he would have got LeBron too when he was
at Adidas and LeBron was ready to sign
he goes we need to offer him 10 million
a year for 10 years 100 million dollar
contract to this 18 year old kid
and rabon's ready to sign and then
Adidas gave him the 10 million but they
changed the structure last minute they
got a little cold feet and they're like
well we don't know if this kid's gonna
work out why don't we make it part of an
incentive based and so they offered him
seven million guaranteed and 3 million a
year of incentives and LeBron turned it
down ends up going Nike never looked
back and like just a huge blunder like
basically this guy's whole life he was
fighting bureaucracy inside companies
and then doing like black market and
gray hat [__] in the like you know in
the streets and every NBA player is like
no sonny their parents know Sunny
because this guy was just working the
streets and like there are certain
companies that have had this Tinder kind
of had this with um what's her name the
Whitney wolf who started bumble she was
kind of doing this from college campus
to college campus like going into the
sorority houses and the Frat houses and
just brute force onboarding all the guys
and girls in one campus so that Tinder
was useful and then throwing parties and
doing stuff like that and like you need
these people these are like
game-changing people for your company I
remember when coinbase went public
uh Brian Armstrong did this long thread
he did something you never see somebody
do which was company goes public they
usually just say generic stuff he
actually talked about like what led
coinbase to be successful and he called
out one guy by name that wasn't his
co-founder wasn't his main investor it
was just an employee and this guy Dan
Romero and he's like and you know it's
basically special thanks to Dan Romero
who like just kind of like Brute Force
built our relationships with banks and
he he basically got them their
relationships with banking partners and
like I think maybe some stuff overseas
um and it was just kind of like one of
those things like dude I don't know how
we're gonna do this I don't know Dan
that's your mission send them on a
mission to go do that and Dan basically
joined coinbase coinbase as an employee
ended up making like 100 million dollars
plus through this process
um and I knew this guy I met him in
college he was in my case yeah didn't he
uh didn't you like used to make fun of
him call him with dweeb I didn't make
fun of him but in my head I did he was
we took a class called computers again I
was going through campus looking for the
easiest sounding classes I took getting
rich I was one class I took another
computers and in computers they were
talking about like that's an exclusive
class it's computers and they were just
talking about like the internet and like
internet I remember like to talk about
net neutrality a ton I was like I don't
know what the hell these guys are
talking about like I couldn't give less
of a [__] about this and there was one
guy that every class had like strong
opinions was super informed I was like
man who is this like teacher's pet
that's just like is he trying to impress
him I was like no I don't even think
he's trying to impress him I think he
actually is just nerdy about this stuff
he just listened [__] just loves
the internet this guy like wants to make
out with the internet I just remember
sitting in the back of class like I was
like thank you for talking so much Dan
Romero because I don't have to say a
word in this class and um
it's sort of like you know Revenge of
the Nerds in a way it's like jokes on
you like this guy's passion and
enthusiasm about the internet and
technology is what led him early into
crypto was led him to pick coinbase and
ended up you know like his passion for
that led him to be a key person there
this guy made 100 million hundreds of
millions of dollars probably is retired
and uh and got to do what he loved the
whole time and so like you know I I used
to make fun of people who were like you
know overly enthusiastic and now
I preached that you need like enthusiasm
is massively underrated and more people
dude and he's got a super handsome uh
headshot now in LinkedIn Dan Romero does
because you can afford a whole you know
glow up if you uh if you get that
coinbase IPO and early Bitcoin money
he's got great hair this guy's
definitely takes him he's a good looking
guy
power himself and he just bought uh 13
million dollars worth of a 13 million
dollar property in Venice and another
one in Park City Dan Juan
yeah down one for sure
and you can tell that he's ripped too
like this guy's definitely has abs Dan
won
good job Dan
I'm just like you just Google him and
see his face you know this guy's fit
[Laughter]
no nfts uh just lift up your shirt six
inches I'll tell you
qualify so um dude this guy's Sunny
sounds awesome I I did see the movie and
they made him look like a guy who could
just put up with a whole lot of pain
that's what they made him look like
um they made him look like a guy who
like he would just get [__] on
constantly and he always pulled through
that's what they made him look like uh
and they also made him look exhausted
and terribly unhealthy which is the
price it's kind of true yeah they made
him look horrible and if you look at
photos of him granted he's like looks
like he's he was born in 1938 I think so
like you know you are what you are at
that point but like he he definitely
looks like he smoked a lot of cigarettes
that sounds very old is that I looked
him up on Wikipedia I think it's 38.
he's 83. wow
yeah so he you know
he's alive and and by the way the guy's
name is actually John Paul Vincent
Vaccaro
change is sunny
God damn I like
you have to have a nickname that
everybody in your town knows you by
that's like
to me that's like one of the great
honors of life it's like yeah his name's
his name's Sean but everybody called him
Sonny whole life everybody called him
sunny it's like that's just like such a
cool I wish I had a calling card like
that that's an Italian thing that's like
I feel like all the there's always a
sunny in the mafia movies that I watch
yeah he operates like a monster for sure
I like this this is a good find I saw
that movie and I thought I don't want
that guy's job it sounded like an
exhausting exhausted
existence
it sounded very challenging but yeah I
did like the movie they made him they
made Phil Knight look a little goofy
which I'm a big Phil Knight fan so it
kind of hurt my feelings but uh no I
thought it was a good movie and this is
a good find
all right that's it
that's the Pod let us know who won this
the The Duel the annoying blonde hair
guy who went first or the less annoying
Brown guy who went second that's the pot
[Music]
foreign